I don't know about that was news
submitted by Zachary Webster hey Webster
High School has come under fire for its
humorous cheerleading Awards
oh why like the fattest in the crew best
ass biggest titties I said biggest
cities I want them it'll be a TBD tunica
media award why are they under fire
because the American Civil Liberties
Union
what about [ __ ] them yeah what about
[ __ ] the ACLU they did a lot of great
bang oh they did okay [ __ ] school I mean
sorry that school officials should not
be commenting on students that's really
we're leaders what I thought was like
you know like sometimes when you're
little organizations and clubs so you do
your own piece whatever and then I
thought they're like going in on no more
car washes no more slumber parties I'm
like dude why you trying to be a party
pooper that's like the FBI going after
that swells against it all the FBI don't
be going after the cheerleaders annual
cheerleading banquet and so for the past
five years they've been giving out
awards why do I picture perverted ass
administrators with scorecards like a
cheerleader walks by I gave her titties
of ten I give her ass yeah basically
what this is face of three most improved
two hardest worker but there's also
awards included that's big booty Judy
big booby what and string bean award for
the skinniest truth
and hottest body worst face and best
face word interface parents at this
banquet right I'm assuming and no one
was like this is a little bit weird that
everyone thinks my daughter's Rack is
awesome
probably so that's why they were I would
have been proud for a whole year
oh yeah
my daughter got big-ass titties someone
job annual so I guess they have to think
all season is someone's job to like look
at the tits every day well most
important what you want that's what you
want you get the junk in the trunk you
started at us in a 32a that's big booty
duty and now you're a 35 cm junk in the
trunk award and they give you a [ __ ]
trunk we are saying that these are like
the gag Awards that are meant to be
funny obviously but they're funny if
it's done amongst peers and there's no
adult involved I wonder if it's like
Michael Scott in the office giving out
his awards and like everyone's like the
big booty girls like thanks yeah okay
okay bye pretty much yeah it's all
uncomfortable yeah everyone's like
acknowledging my breasts good like
Angela or or what's her name the bigger
lady the winner of the bigger lady or oh
yeah that's a good hurt what let's say
you put yourself in the cheerleaders
shoes itself in the cheerleaders shoes
right does it mean more to you to get a
big titty award from someone else that's
also 16 or from a adult male who has
banged other many others that's very
true another man to look at but think
about how much credence that comes with
a man who's 500 women are so creative
even grosser now I have to know his
track record I mean am I gonna see his
stats yep but you know your girlfriend
you know Lucy has zero chicks
experience so it's her
or does even mean anything that's what
if it's dan Bilzerian who only bangs ten
but then you're only assuming that women
only want praise for men yeah we better
close to look good if our other women
credibility the credence it could be an
old lady that's motorboated a lot of
ladies exactly if it was Dan Bilzerian
you by the way only bangs hands and if
you and if you're on his boat and you
eat like a little piece of cake or
something and you become a 9 he throws
you off his [ __ ] I would say guys
aren't people I would say guys are not
picky enough they don't know how to
differentiate like yeah those boobs are
big but they're kind of lopsided right
here and they're kind of like you see
that girls can see you act like I don't
know who her surgeon was credence lies
and they're easy with you guys I've been
with you guys the whole time you guys
are just like that's that's um that's a
mating titty
that's different yeah this is a non
mating titty this is a mane I see that
one's luscious that one's I could make
do with this that's available yeah that
one's I'm not the National Geographic
stuff Yeah right well we're kids we
don't have a lot of titties available
nothing like Nat Geo this is tight yeah
then you grow up in here like yeah I
don't need that Jew now nope you need
Nicki not lemo for life because like if
I see a professional ice cream taster
were to tell me like yo this place is
really good oh yeah really yeah but if
it's like I don't know somebody I just
met in their life like a five-year-old
that likes all ice cream yeah yeah you
don't know [ __ ] yeah you think that
[ __ ] big bucket that you get for $5
is really good with the [ __ ] gum bra
ball in it exactly you leave it in the
hot Sun it doesn't even melt yeah but
people usually don't wanna ever mind
people do you know what I could lost it
that's why [ __ ] your brain melted
mid-sentence you just came into our
sitcom cold
[Laughter]
just comes up to side filius walk add
one line and you're like has anyone ever
done that where it's I don't know where
it's like it's like special guest today
is you know Brad Pitt and then he just
walks across and do commercials for last
man on earth no we're in second season
where Will Ferrell's introduced in the
first episode is like the new guest star
and he dies immediately before he even
says a line never says a lot sorry for
the spoiler folks but yeah it's the
first episode it's already old oh they
should have been watching that he should
have been watching that it was good it
was good the first two seasons it
degraded in quality a little bit but the
first two were great yeah yeah so back
to this story here so this high schools
in Wisconsin by the way they like a
cheese just to let you know in Wisconsin
you do what's coming I don't they were
the cheese heads yeah yeah they do go
cheese anyway so ACLU is demanding that
school officials don't cook they gotta
share that quite a bit please that
should have been like without mentioned
that should have been I want to see
their apology though I love the apology
I [ __ ] up a [ __ ] up big time I love
all that [ __ ] so it's a woman coach
person so they're saying that she
should've been or like that the school
said that she was gonna be an assistant
cheer coach but she's still the lead
coach so that's why the ACLU is that
came in with the hell oh they're like oh
look at she's being punished did you
guys see the video of the governor of
Virginia after he got busted for the
black faced controversy stuff Oh what
was that all about I didn't even yeah so
he had like had some [ __ ] in his
yearbook where he was like in blackface
or he was in a cage 80s or something his
friend was a KKK guy and then he wasn't
like a Halloween thing I see I have no
idea why don't know what the convict was
basically like everyone's asked him to
step down and he was apologizing in all
and then during the press conference he
was saying that he was like in the Asia
just like Michael Jackson one time and I
did the moonwalk
and like can you still do the moonwalk
and he he actually looked at the stage
to see if he had enough space to try to
do the moonwalk and then his wife was
like man in the middle of his apology
he's just digging deep anything to
[ __ ] try to relate to people say I'm
sorry he was gonna do the [ __ ] I'm
sorry and [ __ ] so likeable I forgave
them yeah wouldn't it forgave that's the
what that's the real question like can
you still do the moonwalk can I do the
moonwalk watching up like a 55 year old
man in a suit being sad looking at the
stage like be like don't [ __ ] do the
see any the shoes are even slippery
enough I could probably do about three
slides that little moment was worth all
the news that I've watched in like six
years I was great looking up it's great
so are they gonna take away the the big
booty Judy you know what if the
assistant coach that was a head coach
what if she was only like 22 is it so
weird when I played volleyball in high
school that my final year they they
didn't they were they let go over me and
coach so then like the assistant coach
was that she was like this really young
chick and she was horny did she go too
horny Elementary she's young enough to
kind of be in our group yeah then it's
not that weird but if it's unless she's
like trying to be young to fit was just
really cool she was like my one of my
good friends like older sister yeah
confidence early records yeah so maybe
that's what it was where she was young
cuz if she like called one of us like
big booty or you have a nice try or
whatever I'd be like oh thanks yeah yeah
exactly so maybe it's like that but
we're just making it like old ass like
[ __ ] yeah well it's like you're just
playing devil's advocate right now like
what would be the one situation where
that might be okay yeah okay maybe if
they were like younger and they were so
it might not be that crazy [ __ ] we're
carrying this I know you're thinking
right like did she give out awards the
same way like as this horny ass what she
literally just meant that because if she
was then it makes sense yeah yeah cuz
she's young and she's horny so we get
why she came up with the oil it's a
dream come true I just love a reporter
as in somebody how horny was she I think
if everyone was cool with it then I
that's okay if someone felt
uncomfortable or for what if it was
wrong then it's not cool I think that's
all there you accepted in front of your
parents well see that's the thing so a
parent for most school board bull and
then that's when the principal was like
oh they're just meant to be funny
they're just joking around but if
everyone's having a good time I don't
think there's anything wrong with it but
if there are people that feel
uncomfortable and they don't like this
yeah it just takes one person yeah
if they don't like it then what also
kind of sucks is if that's just part of
the culture so in the program they've
been doing this the last 30 years and
then now there's just this one person
are they saying the kids like it but you
know people get made fun of for the
stupid things like I got any fun of her
having a good butt and stuff but that
wasn't cool yet really yeah
so like I feel like if you're already
something you're insecure about at that
age like the string bean one like you
know you can't you need yeah and you're
constantly getting teased about that and
then you hit the string man a word I
don't know that could be I could be
really uncomfortable especially at that
age for me it was I was viewing it more
it feels part of the institution already
so like if you're joint if you joined
cheer you know at the end of the year
they do this then you're like oh maybe I
shouldn't do cheer because yeah maybe
you liked it like cheerleading and I
shouldn't be part of it looks like
people that join frats right they know
there's gonna be hazing involved but
that's different hazing don't even
pledge you know I mean it but that's
different cuz that's not a strong word
and also and also with what happens
that's really cool with like it's like
we get smarter as the whole society and
we understand that oh [ __ ] the stuff
that we used to do back then negatively
affects your emotions your psyche or
whatever so since we learned from that
then that's how we start changing a lot
of the tradition but gee oh that's very
close-minded because towards towards
like sexual harassment like if I wanted
to sexual sexually harass somebody and
and you're saying like well no that's
that's a that's not fair you shouldn't
give me that trophy I'm like one I'm
trying to sexually harass you with the
trophy and I think you're being close to
stopping is she stopping you from doing
yeah that's sad it's just a little bit
sad like what the [ __ ] are these guys
thinking of course it's wrong yeah the
kids the kids don't like this do they
like this it doesn't seem like they do
[Music]